nach schweren gefechten in der
umstrittenen region berg karabach spitzt
sich der konflikt zwischen armenien und
aserbaidschan erneut zu armenien hat das
kriegsrecht verhängt die türkei stellt
sich an die seite bacchus eu europarat
und außenminister heiko maas möchten nun
für eine friedliche lösung sorgen aber
wird ihn das noch gelingen im kaukasus
droht krieg armenien hat nach gefechten
mit seinem nachbarn aserbaidschan das
kriegsrecht verhängt in der unruhe
region berg karabach im südkaukasus sind
nach einer gewalteskalation zwischen den
verfeindeten ländern mehrere menschen
verletzt und getötet worden
der armenische regierungschef nicole
pacini an verkündete daraufhin eine
generalmobilmachung er rief seine
landsleute auf sich für die verteidigung
des vaterlandes bereit zu machen
bei der länder beschuldigten sich am
sonntag gegenseitig die kämpfe in den
frühen morgenstunden ausgelöst zu haben
nach darstellung aus baku und eriwan
dauern diese an armenien und
aserbaidschan befinden sich seit fast 30
jahren im konflikt um die kaukasusregion
berg karabach die mehrheitlich von
armeniern bewohnt ist
und über diesen konflikt möchte ich nun
sprechen mit meinem kollegen julian
röcke hören gibt es schon irgendwelche
erkenntnisse dazu wie es jetzt zu diesen
jüngsten eskalationen gekommen ist
leider ist es so wie so oft weil beide
seiten beschuldigen sich gegenseitig die
hawaiianer sagen dass russland seit
wochen steht das militärgerät nach
armenien verlegt hat und die sich darauf
vorbereitet hätten
die haben ihn ja sagen wiederum dass das
ganze von der türkei ausgeht dass die
türkei also gemeinsame manöver
abgehalten und aller welt
und auch sozusagen dort wachen geliefert
hat was wir allerdings sehen ist das
also beiden selber jetzt sagt dass man
vor denkt dass man sieben dörfer
eingenommen hat insofern sieht es
tatsächlich so aus als würde immer
angefangen hat zu schießen die aus
afghanischen militär zeit folgen
welche geschichte hat denn dieser streit
diese eskalation überhaupt das ist ja
nicht das erste mal ganz genau also in
bergkarabach oder in diesen dieser
komplett region haben wir das was wir in
vielen staaten erlebt haben nach dem
zusammenbruch der sowjetunion nur monate
nach denen sozusagen so bitteren sich
aufgelöst hat hat dort 1991 einen krieg
begonnen in dem ihm eine mehrheitlich
von christen bewohnten gegend eine sehr
kleine gegend nur 50.000 einwohner in
lhasa beitragen gesagt haben wir sind
jetzt ein eigenes land ein
wie gewonnen nicht teil von diesem
muslimischen aserbaidschan sein
völkerrechtlich gehört barbara bach bis
heute zu aserbaidschan
tatsächlich ist es allerdings zu fast 90
prozent von christen bewohnt und
eigentlich ein kleines land war es eben
von armenien sehr stark militärisch
unterstützt wird armenien hat jetzt also
das kriegsrecht verhängt dazu aufgerufen
fürs vaterland sich bereit zu machen wie
gefährlich kann dieser konflikt jetzt
werden stehen die beiden länder jetzt
vor dem krieg also nicht nur am himmel
sondern auch aserbaidschan haben das
kriegsrecht verhängt und haben die
kanadier machen ausgerufen
das heißt also nicht nur dieser kleinen
bergregionen dort durch gekämpft sondern
auch in den hauptstädten jeweils in
jerewan und baku sind militäreinheiten
unterwegs werden leute ins militär
einberufen
also bei damen treten und erklärt dass
die flughäfen für die nächsten tage
nicht mehr zu nutzen sind des landes das
heißt tatsächlich beide länder stellen
sich auf einen längeren konflikt dort
ein und leider haben eben auch ihre
unterstütze die türkei und russland
jeweils schon bekannt gegeben dass sie
ihre seite dort unterstützen werden es
heißt das ganze ist das richtig
brandgefährlich und könnte ein weiterer
stellvertreter komplett in der region
werden mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bet schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren